A home router is a teeny
tiny example of a router.
An ISP or a datacenter might have a
router that looks like a big chunky box
with a lot of cables going into it.
In general, a router is a device that
connects two different IP networks.
It acts as a gateway.
Hosts on one network that want to
send traffic to the other one,
forward that traffic through the router.
While most hosts might
have only one interface
with an interesting IPv4 address on it,
a router will have two or more.
The host on a local network
knows about a default gateway,
which is a router that's connected
toward the rest of the Internet.
Computers that are attached to the same
switch or WiFi access point or
other network hardware
are normally local to each other.
They can directly send packets
to one another without
going through a different network.
And as we saw before they have IP
addresses on the same net block.
But here is Alice over
here at 192.0.2.104.
And here's Chandra over
here at 198.51.100.17.
Those aren't on the same local network.
So if this host wants to
send traffic over here,
it has to pass through this router.
That default gateway may also
have a default gateway itself.
But eventually as you go toward
the rest of the Internet,
you'll eventually reach
the defaultless part.
Where routers on major transit ISPs
know about the global routing table,
the directory of all public IP networks.
Routers up there don't
have default gateways.